you seem very centered you got into a
place where you're making rules up kind
of about what you will do and what you
won't do yeah like I heard that you will
not do shoot a film in the summer you've
just decided I'm not sure but not a
rumor not a rumor so that's real yeah I
don't really
summer pictures anymore i direct in the
summer right produce all summer
activities but you know and made about a
hundred pictures over the past 35 years
no one's called them pictures since 1935
you come out and go I'm making a new
picture you know in the eighties it's
like so you've made a lot we used to
make I mean statistically speaking how
many are good like for you know oh the
sweating and the hair I have it's like a
sable coat year-round you've seen back
there's a vago I'm sure yes I certainly
have many many times so it's like a
babushka yeah have you I got this big
hair and it's hot and you're sweaty very
very warm how good is your movie yet I
mean I myself actually like cold weather
you did I enjoy it because you're tall I
don't understand nothing
see how one would have anything to do
with the other
so yes it's because I'm tall yeah we can
see a polar bear a long way off and we
know what will be attacked no I don't
know what I like I like I just think
that's the way I'm wired I from Boston
Massachusetts I grew up in the sort of
yeah it's me so where do you like what
do you like to go when you have a
vacation you know mostly you know Fred
you know you know we mr. mr. Fred
Armisen we can call it oh yeah this is
you guys have been going out for a while
yes yeah and but so he loves a nicel in
whatever I do I enjoy as well but a
little bit of my also you wouldn't know
from looking at me because I'm so fully
layered by at all times but I do enjoy
swim and so it's been this is how you
swim it looks like you're sorting books
in a library trying to find something to
back the clause Berkeley you like to
swim I do like it I do and but this Fred
like going to them he finds the ocean to
be too strong and unwieldy and does not
does not like sand and see what's no
part of it I can actually look like this
Fred going from Arneson he's just sort
of like a Ike seem he's a very organized
friend I could see him seeing a crab go
by or something like I'm just leaving
it's not for him but it's a very yeah
it's a bit of a yeah I like it I like
sand in the sheets you know
I'm gonna be talking about that stuff I
get what you're saying oh yeah you know
cut to the end of the story it's been a
big heavy heavy arguments in the house
we went where you go where do you go and
cuz I'm Mike so now I feel like if we
find a good a summer sort of a spot then
I could put him under an umbrella and
then he can watch my my cell phone and
stuff and he could watch me swim yeah
you know cuz you have to be careful you
can't swim alone cuz if there's a
burglar
they take your phone you know how it is
burglars aren't on the beach there's a
different there's a different word for
people that steal your phone am i right
what are they called I don't say like a
burglar broke in while it was hit the
beach and took my phone off the stand
that would be a robber
it's a robber yeah okay unless you
unless you went swimming and left your
phone in your house yes and then they
got your phone call you yeah yeah yeah
okay